it doesn't make any sense to have a
woman in mormon underwear on the cover
of sports illustrated no one's saying
more men women can't be athletes exactly
and it also doesn't make any sense to
have a woman in the in a bikini on the
cover of sports illustrated the nobody's
saying women can't wear mormon underwear
nobody's saying women can't wear bikinis
but for us to pretend
that this is some
empowering feminist thing that should be
celebrated that's the lie
hey i'm dave rubin and this is the
reuben report just a quick reminder to
click subscribe on our youtube channel
and hit that little freaking bell over
there so that you actually see the
videos when we put them up and share
them and all that good stuff okay
joining me today is a true fighter for
liberalism in the best sense of the word
and the author of the new book unveiled
how western liberals empower radical
islam jasmine mohammed welcome back to
the reuben report thank you so much for
having me dave it's great to be here i
am glad to have you here my friend this
is your third reuben report appearance
that's right
pretty pretty pretty good
um just quickly before we really get
into it last time you were here i
interviewed you solo and we're going to
recap some of your story which is just
absolutely incredible and then i had you
and uh faizal on together
and uh there was an author here
from um
der spiegel which is a big german
magazine and i had you on talking about
your fight for liberalism and and
leaving radical islam and the rest of it
and faisal as an iraqi refugee coming to
america fighting for freedom and then
der spiegel put me on the cover of the
magazine saying something like i'm the
leader of the alt-right
so i don't know what you're going to do
to me today
that was terrible that was that was
absolutely shocking the word nazi was in
that article too
um
yeah i thought bringing in someone like
you would offer me a little cover and
yet here we are i'm a nazi too dave
all right here all right so let's get
right to it so i i really think you are
one of truly i'm just gonna pat you on
the back side i think you're one of the
most brave fearless like fun joyous
decent people that i know
and uh
and your story is incredible it's it's
incredible and and it's um
it's exactly so much of what is
happening right now so for anyone that
didn't see the original interview can we
just do like a five minute sort of recap
of your life give me your whole life in
five minutes to then so that we can then
shift into this okay um um i'll try as
hard as i can to get into five minutes
but essentially i grew up
in a fundamentalist muslim household in
canada so here i am living in the free
west but
essentially under sharia in my own home
so i feel like i have one foot in each
camp and
so growing up in a fundamentalist muslim
household meant that i went to islamic
schools the hijab was put on me at nine
years old i was forced into a marriage
with a man who turned out to be
jihadi a member of al-qaeda actually he
was one of the people that
trained the terrorists that bombed the
american embassies in tanzania
so
a horrible human being and i was able to
get away i had a daughter with him and
then was able to get away from him and
start a new life with my daughter and i
because we're living in a free secular
democracy that supported me
in that decision
and i stayed quiet living my life with
my daughter for many years until the
infamous episode with
sam harris and ben affleck on bill maher
and um
that day
i was really shocked to see that
everybody on my facebook page and you
know all my friends were totally
supporting ben affleck and you know
against this guy that ben was yelling at
yeah can you just quickly i know most of
my audience knows the story but can you
quickly recap what yeah it's all about
because as you know my wake up i came
from a liberal new york family
and literally my political wake up was
the at the exact same moment like i was
watching it live as you were watching it
live we weren't going to meet for five
years and and so many people not just us
woke up at that very moment yeah it's a
pretty shocking little microcosm of
everything you know
so
essentially sam and bill were talking
about
liberals and how more
sorry
no no you just said bill i just want
everyone to be sure we're talking about
bill maher here yep sam harris and bill
maher were talking about how liberals
will
get so excited and happy and applaud
loudly if we talk about you know
supporting liberal values like women's
equality lgbt equality free speech all
those kinds of things
but then if you talk about how those
values
are nowhere to be seen in the muslim
majority world
or if we talk about the fact that in
countries like egypt like close to 90
percent of people believe that if you
leave the religion of islam that you
should be executed
these are concerning numbers these are
concerning things that we if we
care about liberal values we should care
about them universally not just within
our
you know
close proximity geographically
um and as they were talking
uh ben affleck got really irate and he
started yelling at them and calling them
gross and racist
because he felt like
exactly he was he's he just it's like he
decided that he wanted to be exhibit a
yeah
to embody exactly what they were talking
about you know mr virtue signal
and he went ahead and just did exactly
what they were talking about which was
to get all upset that they were talking
about um islam meanwhile this is the
same person of course that did a movie
criticizing christianity dogma
criticizing dogma in general that's
literally what the entire movie is about
it's it's actually a pretty funny movie
yeah but then why why can't we also
criticize other religions that are
that also deserve criticism
um so how much of it for you was that
sam clearly laid out something that now
i talk about all the time here that
you're allowed not allowed you must
criticize ideas and must not be bigoted
towards people like it's such an obvious
thing when you think about it but people
can't
or not people a certain set of people
seem to be unable to detangle those
things you could criticize the old
testament all you want the new testament
that doesn't mean you hate jews or you
hate christians or you would criticize a
political party that doesn't mean you
hate everyone who say a republican or a
democrat but for some reason with this
issue it seems almost inextricably
intertwined i don't know if it's that in
that intertwined i think that they just
pretend that it is to be perfectly
honest because it's sort of like um
if ilhan omar says something and people
criticize her for what she said the
response is oh you hate her because
she's black and because she's muslim
it's like nobody has mentioned her skin
color or her religion we're talking
about
the words that she has tweeted or the
words that she has said but it's just a
it's just a way i think of
deflecting
um and in fact that episode with with
sam harris the reason why i started to
speak up was because everybody that was
attacking him was attacking him not
because of anything that he said because
everything that he said made absolute
sense
they were attacking him because of his
skin color
because he's american white and male
and so they
that's what they were against so i said
all right well i am you know arab female
and
um
that's good enough
well also you grew up muslim that might
have some value in this equation right
right and then i'll just go ahead and
i'll say the exact same thing that sam
is saying
and then you'll have to respond to the
actual message oh
but did you find out that that was not
the case
yeah no i didn't i didn't calculate
correctly because apparently i can still
be a white supremacist yeah
it's actually pretty so had you ever
was the reason that your wake up in that
moment watching that that
television show was was the reason that
you had never heard it so obviously
explained and seen a reaction that was
so over the top like were you thinking
sort of this stuff because for me as a
big lefty and working at the young turks
and all that i had been seeing it but
suddenly it was like whoa that's all of
it right there yeah
so i hadn't been seeing it at all and in
fact when sam started to speak and he
started to talk about the concentric
circles and everything i started to get
really excited because
mainstream media i mean this guy is on
bill maher's show i've been watching
bill maher since i was a teenager
and i was so excited that this this is
start you know it's part of mainstream
conversation now people are going to
start talking about this people are
going to talk about people being hacked
to death in the streets of bangladesh or
people being you know
whipped in the streets of saudi arabia
or women going to prison in iran i mean
et cetera except all of these problems
in the muslim world that we should be
addressing
being you know gay people being executed
in 15 muslim majority countries why
isn't this a conversation why hasn't
anybody mentioned this we have a whole
month where we have pride flags
everywhere but that never comes up again
it's only people within this close
geographical proximity so i was really
excited to hear sam and bill having this
conversation
and then it was such
an incredible punch to the gut
to have ben affleck shut them down
because i was like oh my god like really
like can you just
please you know you don't understand
anything about this world you don't
understand the value of these men
finally speaking up
and for him to shut them down was you
know it was really hurtful it was really
upsetting
so let's back up for a second because
you're talking about the geography
related to all this and you've mentioned
other couple other countries that are
not that close to canada and the us but
you grew up with a lot of those rules in
canada
i think that's hard for a lot of people
to understand can you just talk i know
we've done this before and we'll
actually link to your original video in
this but can you talk a little bit more
about like i don't think people can
really understand that you you grew up
canadian in western you know in a
western country and lived under some of
these laws absolutely and in fact you
know like faisal grew up in iraq and him
and i talk all the time about how his
upbringing was more liberal more liberal
than mine was and that has a lot to do
with the fact that when you're not in
almost a majority country sometimes the
family members become a lot more zealous
because they're super concerned about
you picking up ideas from the
non-believers so they want to have like
a very tight
you know that they want to make sure
that your bubble that you live in is
very separated from the non-believers
outside were your parents um first
generation immigrants to canada yeah and
were they fundamentalist on the way in
no they weren't so um neither of them
were practicing really they were just
born muslim
and pretty secular upbringings
and it wasn't until
well they separated my mom and dad
separated and my mom was alone with
three kids
and she started looking for support
started looking for
community and so she went looking at the
mosque she went to the mosque and that's
where she found a man who um offered to
take her on as his second concurrent
wife so he was already married already
had three kids this is in canada this is
in canada and i have to express like
this these are very common things like
this isn't just my story
this is very common that there are
people that i speak to all over the
states all over the netherlands all over
europe all over the uk scotland
everywhere that tell me about how they
also grew up in
households with more than one mother
more than one wife to the husband
and going to islamic schools and living
in their own little bubble of sharia
this is you know it's it's not like my
story is unique
are the are they technically married
like are the mosques actually performing
that marriage it's obviously not done in
a civil way in a place like him yeah so
that's exactly it so the first wife
would be his legal wife
and then the second wife third fourth
would be islamically married so yes the
mosques are performing these marriages
and quite often what ends up happening
is he will go on social assistance and
that each one of the other wives will
apply as single moms
and quite often the government is sort
of aware of what's going on but they
don't do anything about it this is an
issue in canada where there's like
millions of dollars spent in this
direction but they don't want to say
anything about it because of course
cultural relativism and feel even though
it's against the law
this is the subtitle of my book
it's because things are against the law
but when a muslim does it
people are afraid to touch it with a
10-foot pole because they don't want to
come off as being racist or islamophobic
or bigoted or whatever and then of
course that is a real slippery slope
that can lead to things like the rape
gangs and rotherham were
journalists politicians you know
everybody was too scared to say anything
because
most of these rape gangs were being led
by pakistani muslim men
and so
they stayed quiet about it and that of
course allowed these girls some as young
as 11 to continue to be raped
so that's what happens when we turn a
blind eye
there are victims under there
so so all right so the subtitle of the
book uh how western liberals empower
radical islam
you wake up
you've lived through this
um you it sounds like basically
immediately you realized oops this isn't
going to be as great as i thought like
you sort of thought the damn was gonna
break and it was like holy cow people
are gonna
start understanding the left's gonna
wake up liberals are gonna wake up you
quickly found out that wasn't what was
happening
what else happened at that time did you
start seeing support from places maybe
you didn't think you were going to get
support yeah so initially i came out as
anonymous
and
i started getting messages
like crazy from people all over the
muslim world
who were you know excited that i was
telling my story happy that i was
telling my story and asking me to be
their voice so telling me their stories
as well
and then i got to a certain you know it
wasn't very long i was probably about a
year into it when i started to just feel
ashamed i was like here i am using a
fake you know confessions of an
ex-muslim because i'm afraid to use my
real name right that was your original
that was my original thing and i don't
have my face out there and these are
people that are living in countries like
pakistan where they can go to prison for
you know just questioning anything to do
with the religion that would be
considered blasphemy and thrown in
prison
and so i started to feel like here i am
living in a free secular country
i have to
be you know i got a man up i gotta put
my face out there put my name out there
and so that's actually what
initially was the catalyst for me to
start speaking so that was their support
and that it still is their support that
keeps me going especially women in
countries like iran when they take off
their hijab and they're posting videos
um
women in saudi arabia taking off their
hubs and burning them
like all the women all over the muslim
majority world that are fighting back
against the literal patriarchy
um but those are the women that i really
want to be here to support and uh
they're they're the fuel are you are you
shocked at how fearful people are in the
west right like you're just describing
these incredibly brave people who
literally could lose their life and
their everything else but that people in
the west
are afraid to say what they think be who
they are and the rest of it yeah
absolutely it makes me it it's it's
infuriating actually um
like i mentioned these people can go to
prison and they can be killed for
speaking out
and
over here you've got people where it's
your first amendment to free speech is
like there's a reason why it's the in
the first amendment it's that important
and they are instead
you know they've got these self-imposed
blasphemy laws like in saudi arabia and
pakistan and all those other countries
the government will get you for speaking
out but here they get each other yeah
like it's really shocking to me and and
sad were you also shocked that because
there is a world of either ex-muslims or
muslim reformers or whatever and i've
had some of them on the show actually
were you shocked how um sort of at odds
even that world sort of seemed to be so
that it's
many times someone like you comes out
you defend the liberalism and then
they'll even those guys who are
supposedly the reformers will even
attack someone like you
yeah i think that there's always you
know the thing is about
people that leave their communities
you know
it's like herding cats yeah yeah
we're not the we're not the the wall
flowers right the wallflowers are still
in the religion
so um
i think that when you get a bunch of
people that are willing to be vocal in
this sphere or willing to walk away from
their communities
those people are usually they've got
some fight in them
and so you see all sorts of
you know
schisms and and sometimes negative
interactions but i don't necessarily see
that as a bad thing i come from a world
where everybody followed the exact same
book
and everybody had to
you know in in in islam it's called the
suratul mustafi so it's this long thin
almost like a tightrope
and underneath the tightrope is hell
and you have to walk this long straight
path
narrow path and you have to be very very
careful never to stray or you're going
to burn in hell for eternity
so
there was no variation in anything like
everybody thought the same everybody
spoke the same everybody acted the same
and so now out here in the real world
where people have different ideas and
people disagree and whatever i don't see
that as a bad thing
i'm happy to see it yeah it's
interesting because
when i started doing some shows with
people like you the amount of hate i got
from that crew the supposed reformer
crew i was just like you know what i
tried it was an interesting thing i
thought this was a nice way of defending
liberalism and basically i haven't
touched this topic and probably since
the literally the last time you were
here which is almost three years ago so
even though i had phase line a few weeks
ago we really just talked about foreign
policy and geopolitics
because there's a certain opportunity
cost that comes with defending
liberalism in liberal western societies
which is quite bizarre
yeah yeah but you know what you're doing
it
i guess we're doing the best we can
we're doing the best do you think so
this is this is sort of where i'm at
with with all of this and we don't have
to make this specifically about religion
do you think
there is something inherently flawed or
that liberalism has some sort of
weakness that these people have been
able to either exploit or
or unearth that maybe we couldn't see
before
yeah unfortunately i think that that's
true and they've been very transparent
about that so the muslim brotherhood
clearly said that we're going to
spread islam without raising a single
sword and the way that we're going to do
that is through three means
number one through the wombs of muslim
mothers number two through immigration
and number three through using secular
laws against themselves and in fact
hasan al-banna who is tariq ramadan's
grandfather so the the person who
started the muslim brotherhood
said we need to have our children in the
west so that they can understand the
western minds so that we know how to
infiltrate basically because us because
he was egyptian
you know it doesn't matter even if we
live in the west we're never really
going to understand their mindset we're
not going to know how to work against it
so um
yeah that was part of the plan so what
do you think the weakness is of
liberalism i mean you know you know i
talk about classical liberalism a lot i
do believe that it is the best set of
ideas to create the most human
flourishing and allow people to be
themselves and govern themselves and
live the lives they want to live but i
have come to a certain unfortunate
conclusion that it might have a soft
spot and they've gone for it what do you
think it is about not what they're
trying to do but what do you do you
think there is something within
liberalism itself that i think that the
problem with liberalism is that people
aren't
like
standing up for liberalism as much as
they should so whatever do you think
that's an inherent problem of liberal of
the openness of liberalism allows that
to happen like that's i'm starting to
get to the spot i'll tell you what i'll
tell you what i mean so i gave the
example of the of the rape gangs in the
uk
also in the uk you know once every hour
a girl is
um goes to the emergency room like
there's a case reported at fgm female
genital mutilation
for the past 30 years it's been against
the law there but nobody's ever been
prosecuted there's my personal story in
there of me going to you know to the
judge basically
it got you know went through social
services and through um
police and everything and i ended up
going to family court
where i told them about how my family
were beating me and i showed them the
bruises and they they all understood
what was going on and in the end the
judge said
listen you come from a culture where
that's acceptable that's the way your
family chooses to discipline you so
that's their right unbelievable so this
is what i mean it if we stood by our
principles if we stood by our values
and we said look this is what liberalism
means
and
this is the stop sign
right but
this failure that i think you're seeing
and that i'm seeing too is that there's
no stop sign where's the boundary you
have to have a point where you say
yes we're inclusive yes we accept you
up until then up until you cross this
line right here so would you say that
it's it's moral relativism that you
referenced earlier that has somehow
seeped into liberalism i mean to me
that's what created the progressives you
had decent liberals who just wanted you
know like even now when they're virtue
signaling about gays and blacks and
muslims i'm like most of you aren't bad
people you're just confused about what
the issues are and you're confused about
what freedom is um but then this moral
relativism seeps in and for some reason
i mean i think it's probably for a whole
other show but i mean i do have a lot of
thoughts on why liberalism has this soft
underbelly that accepts that where
something like conservatism
maybe because of a religious
connection which is a pretty bizarre
position for someone like you to have to
think about
has protections against it
yeah i think that
actually the biggest problem i can see
with the progressives right now is that
they remind me too much of
religious people it reminds me too much
of the world that i walked away from
so these progressives these you know the
far left ones
um you know they've got this cancel
culture for example well you see that
with scientologists you know you're a
repre you're a
suppressive person muslims will kill you
if you leave the the religion um you can
be excommunicated ostracized or
cancelled do you know what i mean like
there's so many
that's our friend people goes calls it a
secular religion absolutely yeah radical
leftism
so when we're talking about liberalism
i'm i'm i'm here for it
but then when we start to talk about
this far left progressive secular
religion people those guys remind me so
much
of the guys that i just ran away from
like risked my life and risked my
daughter's life to get away from so i
want nothing to do with them just as
much as i want nothing to do with them
but the problem is here in the middle
where there's you know
rational-minded people we're just
these guys on both sides are just nasty
yeah
you know what i mean like if you think
of like the westboro baptist church
people standing there with like god
hates [ __ ] or or the jihadis with their
you know behead anybody who criticizes
islam both bad i'm happy to criticize
both yeah and then on this side you've
got those guys that were blocking that
old lady and her walker that was trying
to get to your talk yeah you know what i
mean like his husband was fought the
nazis in world war ii and they're
calling her a nazi unbelievable so i
mean they're just like angry
people that are unwilling to engage in
you know just decent
interaction with other human beings but
they want people to walk on that long
straight narrow path they decide what
that long straight narrow path is right
and they want everybody to walk on it
and um that's what i'm totally against
in a weird way though is it um
is it scary for you as someone that left
a fundamentalist line of thinking
to see that as the secularists become
fundamentalists like it almost seems to
me like that everything happening right
now
is just the end of secularism which
really blows that's the best
well well that it almost seems like what
the progressives are offering us
and this and the moral relativism and
post-modernism and identity politics and
all of those things which is so the
reverse of liberalism and western belief
that that is secularism on steroids you
know what i mean like i truly hate to
say that
i think that well as you know i'm a
college professor and my students are
like the 18 to 25 demographic and i
really
do believe maybe i'm being a hopeless
optimist right now but i really sort of
have to be in your business wouldn't you
yeah i feel like there is like a post
woke
you know they're called zoomers now yeah
i i really feel that they
they roll their eyes at all of these
things you know and
um
i honestly feel like those people that
we're talking against i feel like
they're going to fizzle themselves out
before they're able to bring down
secularism or liberalism like i really
you know
do you see signs of that so your signs
are saying or that that young people now
that you're teaching are and i believe i
see plenty of that when i go to colleges
like yeah there's plenty of people
standing up against this yeah but i
would say for as many as that stand up
against it we just don't know how many
are afraid to for the same that's
exactly it and that's exactly what the
religious thing reminds me of too
because when i was a muslim and i was
doubting and i was questioning and i
didn't like the things that i was
hearing i wasn't going to say anything
because i'm going to be attacked for it
and i'm going to be not just attacked
i'm going to be demonized for it right i
mean if i just say these things it's
like oh you're how could you question
the faith how you you're a non-believer
you're
us and them you're now like the enemy
and it's exactly the same thing that's
happening over here i mean my daughter's
in you know she's studying to be a
social worker
and in that field it's
super left i mean she had a question in
one of her final exams
it said um gender is a social construct
true or false
and she's like mom i had to answer it
incorrectly to get the grades you know
what i mean and so many stories like
that
and so yeah she bites her tongue in
class because she wants to pass
and sometimes in discussions she'll
notice that there are other people that
are sort of saying things too
but like she was you know telling me the
other day as soon as the discussion
started her teacher just shut it down
and was like uh different people have
different opinions different people and
she's like
literally that's the point of school is
that different people have different
opinions like why why are you guys
scared to even have these conversations
is that a doubly uh
intense thing for you because not only
your your backstory and everything that
you've told us here you're also on
college campuses so you're like really
hit with this monster all the time
basically yeah yeah yeah i try to um
as much as i can just focus on all of
the positive things that are going on
you know it but it does bring me down
like quite often i just feel like i just
want to quit everything and just move to
a deserted island
but
you know there's there are enough things
that i see that that keep me going and
i'm looking into some land somewhere
yeah i don't want to say it well
don't say it on air did i ever tell you
about the time i think i was speaking at
university of arizona and
i was a couple hundred kids and there
was a kid towards the back who was brown
skinned i happened to see him and it
wasn't that brown skin that alerted me
in any way it was that he looked very
glassed over in his face like really
sort of lost and and sort of and you can
pick that you speak in front of public
sometimes your eye just gets caught to a
particular person it might be the body
language or whatever it is and i could
see he was also really sweaty and he
kind of looked glossed over and i just
was i was a little nervous like you just
don't know any at these days these days
you just whatever yeah anyway i'm doing
the meet and greet after and i see him
in the line and he comes up to me
and he gets really close to me and he
says can i hug you
and he hugs me
and then he says i'm like you
and i didn't know what he meant at first
and then it took me a second and then he
said i'm gay and oh and he had his name
was muhammad and
i thought this is just so
twisted that someone like him
you know has to live in fear
while he lives in arizona yeah and it's
like you see this over and over and over
yeah and that's why it's so meaningful
when you go and do these talks that's
why it's so meaningful when sam was on
bill maher's show or it's so meaningful
when sam was doing his ted talk and he
was talking about women in afghanistan
having to cover themselves up in bags
and why we don't care about that and why
we're not talking about that
it's so meaningful to people like me and
this guy who are brought up and i mean
him probably
you know it's arizona and for me it's
canada like you think that these kinds
of things only happen over there in
these countries under these strict
sharia regimes
but
anywhere where within you know these
these ideas cross borders right yeah so
if we're within that community
you really have to keep your
you know
your personal thoughts your doubts your
homosexuality your feminism your any
ideas that go that are sort of dissident
in any way you have to be so quiet about
it so to see somebody else talking about
it
um is is just incredibly healing so to
be crystal clear for those of us
including the two of us who would never
want anyone to be bigoted towards muslim
people and who want muslim people to
live free and practice their religion
however they want all people to live
free of course
um
what do you think the reformers are the
reformers making any headway it's sort
of hard to say and what can
what can the liberals do even because
every time the liberals get involved it
doesn't work out well for the liberals
and then it actually in many ways it
seems like it hurts the reformers
because then yeah then they doubly seem
like sellouts or something but do you
think the reformation you know other
religions have gone through reformations
there's a reason that most jews are
mainly liberal which upsets a lot of
conservative people but they're mainly
liberal usually i think in the in the
better sense of liberalism or
christianity obviously went through a
reformation the church went through a
reformation do you sense that islam can
go through a reformation i think that
there are people all over the muslim
world and the western world that are
muslim that are pushing back against
fundamentalism isis did a lot
to help people to see
this is what your religion teaches this
is the end game right here so it got a
lot but what would you say to the people
that say that's not what the religion
teaches or
then i would say
read about the religion
read the quran read the hadith read the
way the prophet lived they
you know
not everything isis did was following
the prophet's example but like the sex
slavery
throwing gay people off of the highest
rooftop you know a lot of things that
they did were just following in the
prophet's footsteps let's not forget
that abu bakr al-baghdadi had a phd in
islamic studies you mean the austere
religion scholar according to the
washington post so this is your question
about what the left can do or what
liberals can do to support the reformers
or to support the people in these
countries that are fighting back is how
about you not support the
fundamentalists how about if you not
call
a terrorist i mean the most vicious
disgusting terrorist leader of the most
horrible terrorist organization we've
ever had to date how about you not call
him an austere scholar how about that
how about you not what do you think is
happening in the newsroom so let's
remove this from college kids
let's remove this from twitter is it
just like
it has this or you think it's just a
just a massive mind virus that has just
run through the institutions
media political well we saw this in
canada too when we were talking about
bringing
justin trudeau was talking about
bringing isis fighters back into canada
and the conservatives were of course
against that idea and so he retorted
with calling the conservative leader
islamophobic
because he didn't want to bring back
isis fighters it's like wait there's a
lot there first wait let's so further up
what was trudeau does anyone think
anyone with half a brain
i'd want to give trudeau more than he
deserves but if you have half a brain
if you leave your country to fight isis
you should not be allowed to come back
or to fight for isis or any terrorist
group yeah you shouldn't be allowed to
come back yeah i don't think that's a
racist thing that's not a zombie it has
nothing to do with race it has nothing
to do with islam it has to do with the
fact that this is a criminal this is
this is a this is a terrorist this is a
horrible human being and so for you to
not be able to introduce you just cannot
recognize that people with brown skin
can be bad that's what it comes down to
if this person
had gone to germany to join the nazis
you know what i mean right and then
decide oh and had burned his passport
because he was like so in support of the
nazis and now he's decided to come back
to canada again there's not going to be
any open arms for that person
but for some reason there's just like
this misfire when the person has brown
skin or when they're muslim it's it's
really the bigotry of low expectations
is what it is is they're not treating
the religion of islam or muslim people
they're not treating them the same as
they would treat everyone else so you
see like when i talk about fgm in the uk
okay once every hour a girl is getting
her clitoris chopped off with a razor
if it was a white family that did this
to their blonde girl those people would
be in prison in a heartbeat right and
everybody yeah front page news everybody
would be just absolutely disgusted and
horrified that anybody could do this to
their own child
but because they're from somalia
then we're just not gonna we're just not
gonna talk about it
do you think all of this ultimately
strengthens the far right because that
seems to be sort of where we're seeing a
lot of that in europe and and i think
we're now starting to see some signs of
it here in the united states and i'm not
talking about the west polar baptist
church or just like you know some
remnant of the kkk but something more
perverse
that feels like maybe it's like starting
to bubble up and it's in a weird way it
makes sense i'm not excusing it but it's
like oh
this sort of makes sense just if you
understand human psychology i think that
those people always existed that are
just you know that hate you know jews
just because they're jews or they hate
somalis just because they have dark skin
or whatever
um
but
in this climate i think it was majid
nawaz that said it or
maybe it was sam harris i can't remember
that if we the rational minded people
are not speaking about these issues
rationally then we are just leaving it
to the irrational
to start having these conversations and
unfortunately what ends up happening is
that the people
that are in this rational sphere
are like craving for anybody to say
these things and then it's unfortunate
that sometimes it comes from
the mouth of you know somebody that
you you know you wish that it would come
from over here you know what i mean and
so then they end up getting support
maybe because of that one issue and i
think that's probably a good example of
that is the way oscar and omani voted
for donald trump was you know exactly
that and then what happened to her after
i mean what happened
but um
actually i never hear of her anymore is
she even has is she even still in the
game she's still only come to think of
it i mean i follow her on twitter i have
not seen a tweet of hers and god knows
how long i don't know if she's i don't
know if it's shadow banning she's
writing a book right now so she's busy
but uh but she's still in the game
but um
you know it's it's like
i can't remember who said this analogy
i'm stealing it from somebody right now
where they said like if you're if the
house is on fire
and you can see the fire everywhere and
you know but all the people are saying
things like
it's a fire of peace
or like there's no problem here then if
somebody's got the door open
even if it's boris johnson or donald
trump or it doesn't matter who it is
somebody's got the door open over there
and they're saying yeah there's a fire
guys i can see it you're gonna head for
that person and be like yes thank you
sanity you know what i mean yeah so i
think that in a way it probably does
you know gets more supporters
um and but that's on us you know like
that's because we're over here
pretending
that everything is fine and that there's
nothing to talk about it's interesting
i'll give you another fire analogy that
is from bill maher he talks about how
liberals for some reason or lefties the
house is burning down and instead of
figuring out how to get out which is
what you're describing they're going
there's a dust bunny in the corner over
there and we better fight about how to
clean up the dust bunny and the whole
house is going to burn down and then you
just got a bunch of people with a lot of
rubble on top of them that's so good i
love that it's just like another version
of what you just said there that's
exactly
it the infighting the infighting instead
of going guys we got a bigger problem
here
yes let's go this way absolutely 100
behind that analogy too and that's
that's something like if we talk about
feminism for example
we're fixated on like our
our air conditioner sexist is
can we build chairs so that men can't
man spread yeah you know what i mean
like we're concerned about all of these
little things and it's like
okay but like how about
these women over here that are being
thrown in prison because they want to
wear what they want to wear you know
what i mean or these women over here
that just want to drive a car or these
women you know come on
yeah
like but but what's the bigotry though
right isn't that the bigger truth well
that's the bigger treatment that's the
bigotry is you're saying i don't care
about those women over there in fact
it's empowering for them to cover
themselves up head to toe in black
in the you know
searing heat of the desert that's great
for them not for me for me i want to go
free the nipple but for them
it's empowering for them to cover
themselves in fact let's celebrate that
and let's put a hijab on barbie and
let's put a a swoosh on a hijab and
let's put on the cover of sports
illustrated is that the part that makes
you crazier than anything else because
when you see this literally you know
they'll have everything you just
described nike that has the hijab and
the whole thing but like they would
never do that for mormon women or where
is the you know uh you know orthodox
jewish women wear like a wig where's the
wig with the logo and like all of these
like in any other religious sense people
would be like this is bananas no one's
saying that women shouldn't be allowed
to do these things no one's saying they
shouldn't be allowed to wear what they
want but sort of like the corporate
give me i was going to say i was going
to say something that was going to it
was going to be a gross sexual reference
just a corporate need to like yeah suck
this thing off yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah no absolutely i mean
it doesn't make any sense to have a
woman in mormon underwear on the cover
of sports illustrated no one saying
mormon women can't be athletes exactly
and it also doesn't make any sense to
have a woman in the in a bikini on the
cover of sports illustrated the nobody's
saying women can't wear mormon underwear
nobody's saying women can't wear bikinis
but for us to pretend
that this is some empowering feminist
thing that should be celebrated that's
the lie
that's the problem right there
do you think part of it is this for the
average person like let's try to give
these people like as much credit as
possible the average
advertising executive out there like
every commercial now that you see
there's always a woman in a hijab in it
you know like literally reese's pieces
yep we all like reese's pieces and i'm a
muslim with reese's pieces okay yeah
it's great fantastic but they do this in
all these commercials now and i don't
for me it's like i of course that's
wonderful that everyone can eat reese's
pieces and everyone can play sports we
love it but they do it because it's
their way of because they think
inclusivity is the number one thing and
how else could you show inclusivity as
opposed to just showing people like so
like they think they're doing something
good but they're they're bizarrely then
protecting things that would never
protect them yeah you're right and
that's why you know technically the
title of my book should have been how
western liberals empower or
inadvertently empower radicalism so yeah
they're not doing it on purpose but they
are doing it essentially
um if we did
look at how everybody just attacked mitt
romney for the fact that he was mormon
do you know what i mean like if we did
take let's say a whole bunch of mormon
symbols
and had them like if nike put their
swoosh on it and if we had them on
reese's pieces commercials and in banana
republic and in marx and spencer and you
know literally any flat surface we just
splashed all of these mormon symbols
all over the place
people
would be
responding
appropriately right people would be like
why are you celebrating mormonism right
why are we valuing this far you know
fundamentalist ideology
this we shouldn't be i don't even i
don't even think they would go that far
i think most people would say mormons
can be whoever they are and do whatever
they want but we just don't need it to
be promoted through all of our
mainstream exactly yeah we don't need to
slap our logo on it yeah you know what i
mean like mattel didn't create mormon
underwear for barbie right why would
they create a hijab for barbie that's
all i'm saying i'm not saying these
people aren't allowed to make whatever
choices they want to
make or wear whatever they want to wear
i'm saying that
we here as
you know free liberal enlightened
country you know of secularists we
really should not be celebrating
fundamentalist
aspects of religion and in fact i just
want to add most muslim women
in america
do not wear hijab
but we're only celebrating the ones that
wear hijab
hillary clinton ignored the woman who
won a gold medal yep she ignored her and
instead focused on this woman over here
because she has a hijab
so we it's very clear that we're not
celebrating
american muslim women in general
or just being inclusive of different
types of americans
we're specifically
supporting
the american women that
look like fundamentalist muslims because
they are wearing the hijab
those are the ones that get celebrated
those are the ones that get on the cover
of magazines those are the ones that get
splashed on every flat surface so as all
of this happens to you and you write a
book about this and you enter the online
world and the whole thing we've talked a
lot about this privately
what do you make of what's happening
broadly speaking on the right
that you're a woman you're brown you're
liberal you're supposed to be hated by
these people if we listen to the just
you know the non-thinking meme that's
out there
um but that's not really the case no i
mean i see a big difference in
just
openness to diversity of ideas so this
long straight path that i was talking
about
i see that very clearly on the left
but on the right
you know i can
talk about the fact that i don't believe
in christianity and i don't believe in
any religion and in fact i think that
it's toxic i can talk about being
pro-choice and i always will be
pro-choice and there's nothing you can
ever say to me that's going to ever get
me to consider not being pro-choice i
can uh and that's a deal breaker for a
lot of conservatives but they're still
happy to talk to you they're so happy to
talk to me because we
agree on certain things like we agree
obviously the way we feel about the left
they agree with how i feel about
fundamentalist islam but we don't
necessarily agree if we're going to be
talking about fundamentalist
christianity there are a lot of secular
people on the right that do agree with
me
but what i mean to say is that
the variation in thought is more
accepted on the right than it is on the
left
not the liberal classical liberal not
the typical left but that little far
left crazies over here there's no
variation in thought like you need to
speak perfectly you can't even get a
pronoun wrong or you are just like evil
right yeah um
but on the right
they're more willing to just sit back
and
disagree with what i have to say but but
not
try to shut me down or not demonize me
or not
you know they wouldn't call me gross and
racist if i had something to say that
completely disagreed with their value
system or with their belief system so as
having said that though there are quite
a few people on the right on the far
right who i've interacted with who
very you know um you know they'll get
mad at me because i have a white husband
and we've made a brown baby so i've now
like ruined that lineage i get that kind
of attacks i get a tax for uh once a
muslim always a muslim we just don't
want your type in our country anyway go
back to where you came from
um
so
just like there are some crazies on this
side there are some crazies on this side
but i think that this middle ground here
is full of both left and right
people
and that's
like i said to you when i was here a few
years ago i really believe that this is
the largest group but we just haven't
found a way to
we're just not as loud like these guys
you know if it bleeds it leads yeah so
these guys are loud and obnoxious and so
then they're getting all the air time
but
you know all the rational people in the
middle i think i think we're the
majority in a weird way it's almost like
we're fighting human psychology yeah to
be rational a couple days ago i spoke at
um sacramento state and we knew that
there were going to be some of these
like white nationalist people there and
a local news crew came and i gave what i
think was probably the best speech in my
life because i've been thinking about a
lot of this because of writing my book
and like i was really sharp and i took
all the questions i could i didn't
censor anybody or anything and it
actually went totally fine there were
there was some minor screaming and like
like minor minor marginal stuff but
nothing happened nobody was attacked
nobody was thrown out no fire alarms
were pulled and then of course
they don't cover it on television
because it was a peaceful exchange of
ideas and yet had anything crazy happen
just one person really screamed and i or
had i
done anything untoward or whatever it's
like now we're on the news yes local
news and then it gets picked up by cnn
and america is racist but whenever you
defuse things as sane
somewhat centrist people
nobody has a freaking clue absolutely
this is a problem this is a problem
because then people start to feel like
the world's gone crazy and they start to
feel like things are way worse than they
really are
i don't think and and we give them too
much because we think that things are so
bad we give them too much credence
there's too much credibility given to
these people who say crazy stuff like
why are we even paying attention to them
this you know jessica yaniv from my
hometown of vancouver bc you know
wanted so went to estheticians and
insisted that they wax
jessica's balls right so to be clear she
is a biological male nobody has a
problem with her identifying as a trans
person yeah but she has balls yeah she
chest balls and i there are many reasons
why these women
refused one of which being it's a
completely different
skill set as an esthetician you know
right yeah yeah yeah there's probably a
different tool these are very different
things very different wax different
methods you know what i mean like these
are physically very different body parts
and so they just these women just
weren't
they didn't have the knowledge required
to do this and she took that and
ran with it to the human rights tribunal
and said that it was a um you know
violation of her rights et cetera et
cetera
oh my god how much air time she got yeah
right and like ricky gervais is tweeting
about her and it's just like all over
the place blair did a really great video
on her and blaire white yeah um just
like all over the news and that is
somebody that as a society we should
just be
either ignoring
you know what i mean like it should have
just been
luckily the human rights tribunal um
the judgment it was against her yeah so
everything turned out fine in the end
but
she just got way too much air time we
spent too much time and energy talking
about somebody like that
and so it makes everybody say things
like wow the trans community are nuts
like no jessica geneva's nuts yeah but
we ignore all the all the ones that are
just living their lives that's that's
what i always say about the bathroom
thing it's like trans people have been
going to whatever bathroom they wanted
to pretty much forever and there's
really been no issues with it and now we
find one issue that we blow it up into a
national emergency where suddenly
literally when it was happening in north
carolina i think obama was like we're
cutting funding to the state if they
don't and it's like i think we might
have blown this thing out of proportion
guys totally totally being blown out of
proportion all the time and i think that
that's
that's really dangerous and i just wish
that we could get to the point where we
just ignore stupid things
you know like there was um was a bed
bath and beyond that
they had to take down their pumpkins
they had black pumpkins
and they said we got to take these
pumpkins off the shelves because they're
pumpkins with blackface like
jack-o-lanterns right there i missed
this one so now i miss this one yeah so
when people when somebody right they
still do have the 20 off coupon so right
because people freak about those things
yeah okay good but i mean if you're bed
bath and beyond and you get a letter
from a nut job saying
you need to take these off the shelves
because these jack-o-lanterns have
blackface you know what send them a 20
coupon yeah yeah
yeah just like shh go back
home everything's gonna be okay you
don't take them off the shelves yeah you
don't listen to these idiots you know
what i mean but that also it still gets
back to that thing about the weakness of
liberalism i think and i hate to say it
like i truly hate to say it
that it's like these institutions and
companies to watch social justice infect
everything and for some reason
liberals and of course i don't mean
everybody but like
they don't stand up for it they always
take the path of least resistance and i
think that's the problem i don't
necessarily think that liberalism is the
problem i think that the problem is that
liberals are not standing up for liberal
values and we talked about this you know
when i was here last time before just
western values enlightenment values why
do we feel like that's a bad thing to
support well now the memes out there
that well it was all white men it was
john locke and it was all white men adam
smith it was all white
john
white guy so you know yeah it's like in
all of these colleges now where they're
taking down all the pictures of the
poets and and and uh statues because
these are all white men most of them
wrote poetry in the name of whiteness
goodness yeah like the point is that
that's really the problem right there
that's the crux of the issue right there
is they're not looking at the value
itself or the issue itself but they're
looking at the color of the skin
of the people and that works both ways
too right so to go back to the rotherham
rape gangs that was the problem there
too instead of just looking and saying
oh my god thousands upon thousands of
girls are being raped
we need to do something about that they
went wait a minute but they're being
raped by men with brown skin so hold up
you know we have to
address this differently no you don't
yeah those are still girls being raped
it doesn't matter if you're being raped
by white men or black men or brown men
irrelevant is the other part of this and
we sort of referenced this earlier that
like so when there were all those rapes
at uh in germany a couple years ago on
new year's and they didn't want and they
sort of covered it up and basically the
only people that that were talking about
it online were people on the right and
breitbart was covering it and drudge
maybe and a few things like that
and then and then so then what happens
is the mainstream media is like see the
way they're they're blowing this thing
out of proportion but then regular
germans who i've talked to said no this
was real this was a real thing that
happened and then what happens is the
people who were like and then it came
out that it was really happening like it
was very clear that it was happening and
then maybe some minor media touched it
but basically it makes those people who
were the ones screaming about it first
go
well the media is against us and this is
a horrible stuff and now like it feeds
there it feeds the narrative too it does
it does unfortunately
yeah
and
not only does it feed the narrative it
feeds the hate too it feed it feeds
those insidious people so like in sweden
for example where they refuse to talk
about anti-semitism and how it has risen
so much so now it's like it's i think it
went from something like 12
to like 50
or something like that like it just
keeps on growing as long as you don't
talk about it as long as you don't
identify it as long as you don't try to
fix it it's just going to continue to
fester and is that what you want like
really that can't be what they want they
don't want to be
empowering those people to just keep
going because nobody's talking about it
you know we're getting away with it you
know i was on tour with jordan and we
went all over the world and we went to
all the nordic countries in sweden we
ended up doing two shows because the
first show sold out in literally 30
seconds
and we were there and everyone you know
if you listen to all the lefties they
would say well we should be more like
sweden we should be more like sweden and
the nordic countries everyone that came
to our shows and i get it's a
self-selected group of people they're
completely afraid of saying what they
think yes that was like the running
theme the the shows there when we got on
stage it was like people were like it
was like star like they were like
yeah like that yeah it was actually
crazy i can't get the vision though of
if nine-year-old yasmin
in full garb would have known that you
know 20 some odd years later she'd be on
youtube talking about waxing people's
balls i've had that in my head for the
last five minutes and i just have to get
it out otherwise
[Laughter]
yeah um but there's a beauty to that
isn't it i think they're really good
i wish i i wish i could have you know
known that any of this was even an
option back then
because back then this there was there
was no internet there was no way for us
to all communicate there was no way for
these voices to be heard right
mainstream media were just deciding what
was going to go on our little tv with
five channels and that was it you know
um
and i really felt so
alone
and so stuck
and really crazy because everybody
around me
it i describe it like a school of fish
you know everybody's going in this
direction
and
you don't really think about it you're
not given the opportunity to think about
it you just move along with them and if
you move on your own
uh it's just it's just
so terrifying
but even as a kid i was always
questioning things and things didn't
make sense to me like imagine being a
nine-year-old girl being told that you
need to revere a man
a 53 year old man that raped a
nine-year-old girl like you have to love
him more than you love yourself and i
you know that's pretty gross like it's
that's
that's traumatizing
to have to
stop the part of your brain that is
disgusted at the prophet of allah you
know what i mean because how could you
like he's like the most perfect example
of humanity for all time and so you you
get filled with this self-hate and the
self-doubt
um but i think that what you're doing
now with these youtube videos and you
know obviously um twitter facebook
social media in general with people
being allowed to express their views
there's no gatekeepers well i mean they
are but
to a lesser extent
so not only can we reach people like
that young man you spoke about in
arizona
but we can reach people in iran and
saudi arabia and sudan and somalia and
pakistan and bangladesh it's crazy
but they
just like i was as a kid growing up in
canada feeling you know crazy because i
don't want to
express how i'm feeling because
everybody around me disagrees with me
they have an outlet now
and what they're living of course is way
worse than what i was living because at
least i got to see both worlds
i got to see it outside of the bubble i
wasn't part of it but i saw it over
there and i knew that there was a
reality that was way better than this
reality in here
and so i had something to strive for
whereas in a lot of those countries up
until recently
they couldn't even see it they didn't
know that it existed there's a great
quote in the uh documentary
misrepresentation where they say you
cannot be what you cannot see
and that was exactly it right there
right like i saw
sheryl sandberg i saw you know um
at the time
it's kind of ironic now but sinead
o'connor and how she cut that picture
you know
so and i saw madonna fighting against
religion and all of those things
you know john lennon's imagine no
religion there were there were
ideas
permeating through that bubble into my
head
but i still felt very alone very
separate very
you know just scared
and so i i wish that
i had been able you know
i'm so happy now yeah you're doing it
now get that
other side
so just one more thing for you although
that was a beautiful closing to an
interview um so just can you just talk a
little bit about how difficult it was to
publish the book because you ultimately
self-publish
and you know we've talked about it
privately but you said to me you know
basically
if this was about leaving christianity
or leaving judaism or leaving mormonism
or
certainly leaving scientology or
whatever else yep you're going to get a
book deal real quick you're going to be
having you know a netflix special and
there'll be a documentary and a
fiction version
yeah and this is that's going back to
that whole thing of identity again right
so if i had gone through this exact same
experience somebody else went through it
leaving the westboro baptist church or
leaving
hasidic judaism or
leaving you know the mormon church
whatever it is
they will
not touch my story with a 10 foot pole
because of the color of my skin and
because of the fact that i came
from a non-white
what's viewed as a non-white religion
so they're not
comfortable criticizing or celebrating
somebody who is criticizing
the ideology of the brown people
but
the
issues within islam are much much more
exaggerated like they're much worse
than they are from you know scientology
or westboro baptist or any of those
other fundamentalist christian
ideologies that people are happy to
speak out against
please speak out against these that's
fantastic that there's a definitely a
problem there and we definitely should
celebrate people like leah remini or
megan phelps roper or
anybody that leaves these horrible
ideologies please celebrate those people
but can we also celebrate
like all people yeah what about ayan
hercieli what about what she has
overcome i can't think of a single human
being that has overcome more than what
that woman has overcome
but we she's not she's the barometer to
me if you say to somebody what do you
think about ion hersely no i guess some
people aren't going to know her but if
you know her and you have to think for a
second
before answering how wonderful she is
and brave and all those things it's like
you are confused and if she had white
skin and blonde hair and overcame those
things in a western context
we'd have statues of her yeah you know
what i mean like people would definitely
recognize
how amazing she is but because she's
from a different part of the world and
her skin is a different color then
they're not willing to celebrate her and
to me that is the epitome of racism
that's a that's a second great ending by
you you're getting good at this all
right you guys can get unveiled at
yasmin's website which is
yasminahamic.com if you're looking for
more honest and thoughtful conversations
about spirituality instead of non-stop
yelling check out our spirituality
playlist and if you want to watch full
interviews on a variety of topics check
out our full episode playlist they're
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell